well
[Music]
hello today is Tuesday the 8th of always and
these are the most relevant news
of the day today at one thirty in the
morning there was a
gunfight that left a robbery suspect
dead this happened in a development
of  luxurious houses near tropicana and
durango according to official reports the
suspect was killed at the scene of the
crime when he tried to hit the owner
of the house with a hammer the
metropolitan police continue the investigation
of the facts
the lawyers of the president of trump have
submitted an appeal for  annul the
victory of the president to the reader job
airén before the supreme court of justice
in the state of nevada yesterday the
legal team of the president of trump filed
a countersuit to reverse the ruling
that indicated that there is no evidence of
illegal votes in the contest the state
certified  has given bailén as the
legitimate winner by a margin of 33 thousand votes
registrations for
the third round are now open  wave of
the clark county aid program that assists
small businesses affected by the
pandemic with at least 30 thousand dollars
for rent expenses, public services
and payment to employees, priority will be given
to the first registrants, however,
businesses that have already received this
help can still be reapplied
for more information visit our
news now dotcom website
home sales continue to break
records according to real estate experts
median home sales price
in southern nevada last month
was $345,000  this is an
increase of 12.5 percent over
last year while apartment and condo
sales are also up 14%
over last year this
sales rate has impacted the
housing supply in the valley last month
only  they sold 3,300 houses that's
42 percent fewer house sales
than last year let's take a look at the
forecast for  the weather will have a
mostly cloudy day with a maximum of 67
degrees and a minimum of 45 degrees the
temperatures will remain that way for the
rest of the week with a slight drop
for saturday and sunday is all the
information for today i inform you andrés
gonzález  and this was about the
news now in happy spanish
[Music]